all right time to do another movie
review this time we're going back to
kind of our more bread-and-butter stuff
movies we remembered from our childhood
things of that nature because we did a
web series last week and really just one
person [ __ ] I think you know restricted
to the seventies you know if we want to
come into the modern era we're gonna do
that too yeah you know we're gonna do it
across the board I kind of like being
idiosyncratic because we like a lot of
different things so you know and I like
different things than you like invite
you so I think it's kind of cool to just
kind of do whatever you we're trying to
point out cool flicks once that
influenced other movies or ones that we
like we were young or ones that we liked
right now we saw really good horror
movie on Netflix last night what was
that called
welcome to Willis welcome to Willis yeah
horror comedy yeah you know it's not as
zany as one that you know like Tucker
Dale vs. evil which I learned by the way
but this one was a little a little more
subtle but actually I really really
enjoyed it yeah and I had a lot of
old-school throwback so you know
practical effects good writing not PC at
all tons of drug use that's really what
the movie was about about a guy who
whipped up this weird batch of meth that
you know put you in contact with aliens
but yeah I actually do really recommend
that movie because we watched that we
kind of every now and then we get a bee
in her bonnet to do like let's do a
horror movie double feature on Netflix
we'll just pick one at random so we
watched that one which we really liked
and the other one we watched was a
Japanese one called tag yeah which
actually I really like it's strange it
was a very strange movie apparently it's
based on a novel and they've made it was
a hugely successful novel in Japan and I
haven't read it but they made like a
five movie series out of that same novel
over there to like separate to this one
I liked it in the sense that it was kind
of like this weird surreal art film but
then also it was like super over-the-top
hilariously gory yeah yeah I really
enjoyed it very much but today we're
gonna do the black hole yes which is a
Disney classic it was a classic for me I
saw when it came out I was 10 years old
yeah it's on the theater Elsa it was the
same year that alien came out yeah and
the same year the Star Trek motion
picture
yep that's right and 79 yeah this one
was critically panned but critics in
those days basically pant in every
sci-fi movie they just hated sci-fi they
liked art films though well they still
do and I'm not gonna [ __ ] on them for
that because a lot of art films are
really good but a lot some popular
movies are good too right you know you
just kind of have to come out with an
open mind like I don't really like to
make a distinction like oh this is like
a big blockbuster made sure but this
because some of those are good yeah I
tend not to like that kind of thing but
you know you never know I've seen once
I've enjoyed I remember when I went to
go see this movie in the theater though
a mom took me and like the theater was
almost dead yeah and it was in
California in the LA area don't matter
which theater it was it wasn't Mann's
Chinese but it was in that area and they
had a huge opening they had a big wooden
big wooden model of the Cygnus as a
signature Cygnus the Cygnus is the name
of the ship the ship the the the story
centers around this spaceship that looks
like an aircraft carrier and Eiffel
Tower Eiffel Tower had a baby yeah yeah
it kind of looks it's really one of the
coolest spaceships in any sci-fi movie
cuz it doesn't really look like a
spaceship yeah and I don't know I'm not
sure I'd really call this a sci-fi movie
I would not more like a gothic horror
movie kind of in the style of Dracula
and Frankenstein it has a lot of gothic
horror elements to it it just happens to
be in space it's kind of like and I've
seen a couple of people make this
comparison it's kind of like 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea and space and it
also has Maximilian Schell in it who
played Captain Nemo and he's kind of
playing the same type of character in
this right and you can tell that the
writing and execution was kind of done
by older guys another grouts guys in
their 50s and maybe 60s in the Disney
studio system because I felt a lot of
Forbidden Planet in this also yeah and
the way that the dialogue and no one
else Fantasia and Fantasia the end of
the end of it was very night on Bald
Mountain right very
the imagery some people have kind of
panned it for having kind of religious
overtones but no that's just part of
this movie they're making they're kind
of drawn it connects between a black
hole and a black hole being kind of like
a hellish force of destruction and then
this very evil man has stolen this ship
and basically sacrificed his crew for
his own hubris you know for his own
ambitions to go through a black hole and
be to be remembered as like the greatest
human scientist you know in all of
creation even like made this new power
source that could have saved the earth
and fuelled the entire earth there's a
lot of weird subtext and in the end he
pays for his hubris I think they were
kind of making a kind of a metaphor for
like a Faustian comic definitely yeah
basically is going on oh yeah yeah now
the the thing I always found interesting
about this movie and it's weird because
we kind of just yesterday when we were
when we were out for our walk and I was
like man we need another movie to do
what should we do and we couldn't really
think of one cuz we have some like on
the docket and I was like I'm not really
in the mood for that I'm not really in
the mood for that and then for some
reason we started talking about the
black hole yeah and I told him I said
you know what we should do that because
I saw the movie when I was seven when it
came out in the theater
I remember being kind of excited to see
it because it looked like it would be
scary which I've been into scary [ __ ]
since birth pretty much so I was like
excited because I thought it would be
scary
but it didn't make a big impression on
me and I haven't seen it since then
literally the only thing I remembered
about the movie was that there was a red
robot named Maximilian yeah I didn't
really even remember what it looked like
and that iconic shot of that fireball
coming up the thing with the little
silhouette of the people running across
does literally all I remember yeah and
you remember what it was about I
remember anything and I think that
meteor coming down through the hull of
the ship and then running occur I
actually think that that was the
inspiration for Raiders of the Lost Ark
yes I think it was - yeah I definitely
it was a cool shot I mean totally
implausible in space well yeah but
that's one of those things and like
yeah I looked it up evidently Neil
deGrasse Tyson is called the black hole
like the least scientific accurate
science was 79 but yeah one it was 1979
- I kind of feel like yeah it was a
sci-fi movie in the sense that it was
set in space and it was about a black
hole yeah but that's not what they were
really that really doesn't seem like
what they were shooting for now it
seemed more like they really wanted to
do a riff on 2001 I felt like yeah it
worked because it had like a lot of
heavy philosophical type of stuff going
on it was like it was very slow-moving
it was very now one thing that I had
forgotten about it that when we watched
it again last night was it is visually
beautiful yeah it looks and look really
elastic and I didn't remember it looking
that awesome now when you go online and
you look at YouTube you will see cuts
from this movie that's not the movie we
saw we got the HD version we rented it
on YouTube yeah and it looks fantastic
some of the transfers you're seeing on
YouTube look really really bad and
that's not the way it looks when you
rent this movie for 399 you can rent it
yeah there is no DVD or there's a DVD
but it's not a blu-ray this could really
use a blu-ray release is the interesting
thing about it is that and I'm and I
kind of want to get into this too in a
minute is that Disney they kind of
almost didn't really want to release the
DVD of it because it's not one of their
better remembered movies it was app and
and stuff so they actually gave the the
rights to release it on DVD to Anchor
Bay who you know anybody that's super
into cult films and stuff like that
woman who Anchor Bay is they released
most of Lucci of full cheese movies and
things of that nature so they actually
released the black hole then and then
Disney put it out on their own DVD later
but so far they have not really seen fit
to release it on blu-ray which is kind
of a shame because this is a movie where
I think the visuals aren't easily the
best thing it's very pretty movie when
you see it in HD it's very pretty space
is kind of blue it's bluish yeah there's
a lot of colors the interior shots look
good I messed effects and the model work
is really good yeah yeah now I've seen
like I said different transfers on mute
on YouTube that don't look anywhere it's
good it looks terrible that's not the
movie
and they were complaining that you could
see wires and like a robot's hanger I
notice there's any wires either and they
were saying how bad the map shots were
and not last night the match shots look
great you can see a tiny bit of the
green screen like a regular characters
and stuff but it wasn't so bad as to be
distracting and really I liked visually
the best thing about this movie one I
liked it in the background because you
know most sci-fi movies it's like the
background it's just black or every now
that you see a planet over there this
was like a huge blue star field and said
billions and billions of stars and a lot
Carl Sagan just said yeah but it was
just this gorgeous backdrop and the
snack hole was like this swirl it's not
really what a black hole looks like yeah
but you know it looked beautiful in the
movie the ship the Cygnus is awesome it
just it's a gorgeous gorgeous design
especially when it all lights up at the
beginning yes lit up cuz it's got
greenhouses inside the fuselage power
centers and then there's like
scaffolding all around it it looks like
the Eiffel Tower yeah it's fantastic
that's beautiful it was a 12-foot model
in real life and it looked really well
done yeah it was very unique yeah you
know some people say well it's a Star
Wars ripoff they were working on this
actually in the early seventies with the
story it was elements element Star Wars
was so successful but this yeah this was
a project that went back to the early
70s that they had been yeah and it's not
this is not something that you would
really compare a guest's a Star Trek the
motion picture or alien because the
people have really seen those movies yet
yeah they hadn't really influenced the
scene and realism was not what they were
going for in science fiction in certain
generations like Star Wars was not
realistic that's not science that's not
science fiction no I'm like fans that's
a fantasy and it's in there's elements
of western movie and yeah so I'm gonna
say like if people are gonna [ __ ] about
how scientifically inaccurate the black
hole is then you should be able to
should that's so [ __ ] about Star Wars
answer no but like I said sci-fi there's
a difference between hard sci-fi and
science based or science fiction based
fantasy yeah or like the black hole like
like we said
consider it I consider it more a gothic
horror gothic horror movie was a haunted
house in space on helping Spacedock
derelict ghost ship in space and the bad
guy really if you look at him he's
portrayed and there's a lot of visual
cues he's like a vampire in his castle
who's made like a satanic robot army
with basically the undead serving him
yeah there's a lot of elements like that
it yeah it's it's definitely way more
horror movie like that and the
interesting thing too and oh and the
other thing I was gonna say like about
the visuals
I loved the main control room yeah
Maximillian shells character is where
all of the all of the walls of like the
buttons and lights and everything like
that just look like stained glass
windows yeah yeah that is so awesome
yeah this is a beautiful beautiful man
rented in HD it's only 399 it's really
worth the extra dollar because the
visuals are really good it's a really
fun movie to watch yeah and don't
overanalyze things just go with the flow
and realize that you're watching kinda
like vampire Dracula in his space castle
with his army of zombies and demons yeah
think that along that lines and that the
ending is I don't want to spoil
everything
but well a lot of people have seen this
movie yeah maybe somebody might need an
explanation there it kind of has an
infamous ending where they go through
the black hole and it goes into a scene
a lot like 2001 the the what they call
it the star poor the the Stargate CN
where it's like they're pulled to
another universe and they are spinning
and they're hearing voices in their
heads then it zooms in one of the one of
the crew members is a psychic and it
zooms in explicably right it zooms into
her eyeball and she has a vision of
heaven and hell and there's a hellish
vision where the bad guy merges with his
satanic robot and he's in the bowels of
Hell accompanied with his army of zombie
menu that's the part that reminds me of
Fantasia you're like a lot like Fantasia
and then she's kind of extorted out of
Hell by an angelic figure and then
they're on the other side I interpreted
it kind of like her you're seeing her
psychic vision and her near-death
experience as they went through the
black hole he saw that the evildoer was
punished yeah and that they but they
made it through the other side there was
a novelization of the movie that
characterized it worn away where her
psychic abilities she saw that the bad
guy was basically punished for his sins
type of thing just like in a gothic
horror novel and that she used her
psychic abilities to save the rest of
the crew from losing their minds yeah
that's right so that was an alternate
view of it but don't take the ending too
seriously it was gonna continue on they
actually made a comic book but they
never resolved the issue were they it
was gonna be called I think it was
called the other side of the black hole
I think I don't remember exactly what
the name of the comic book was but they
were gonna go on some adventures in the
new universe but it was kind of implied
at the end of this one a little bit a
little bit so you're not talking about
Star Trek or Star Wars you're talking
about Flash Gordon that's the way Flash
Gordon started they went through the
Imperial vortex and come out in a new
universe and that's how slash Gordon
starts know that's kind of that was you
know that was kind of the generation of
writers that wrote this movie very Flash
Gordon there's even a scene where to get
to a space ship that they need to escape
the the Cygnus and they actually go walk
out into space into the out into space
on the unlike right near the accretion
disk of a black hole yes as the ship is
breaking apart now one of the stories is
is that originally that they had space
suits made and the actors didn't want to
wear the space suits they didn't like
them and the director went okay what's
wrong need to stop it without it because
you got to remember there was still a
lot of Flash Gordon style thinking in
the upper management of the of these
things and the audiences of the 1970s
weren't real sci-fi fans
you were a dork if you like sigh yeah I
remember that's I thought was not taken
seriously it was a fantasy type genre
and you could get away with a lot more
back then and you didn't have audiences
that were hyper critical of things they
didn't pick apart special effects they
just oh that was cool yeah that's been a
joint wasn't taken seriously
I liked the movie it was interesting to
watch it was a lot better than I
remembered it it actually was and like I
said I distinctly remember seeing in the
theater I had only remembered like two
things about it so that's why like I
said I'm curious to see it you know 30
odd years later and soon because I
literally remembered nothing about it
but the more I've been reading about it
like his research and the more I saw it
and stuff like that I was like you know
when I was a kid I remember that we had
a record album of the black hole I don't
know if it was the soundtrack or if it
was that read along really good told you
that you know it's a story and it came
with the book so you could like we hang
out with it
it might have been that I can't remember
but it's just weird because there are a
lot of movies that came out around that
time when I was a kid that made a much
bigger impression than this one did and
I'm not sure why this one didn't because
other movies came out after this I guess
and Empire Strikes Back wasn't to focus
this seems like something that really
would have been like right up my alley
and like I said I wanted to see it when
we went to see in theatres because it
looked scary and I love scary stuff I
liked it I liked it as a kid I didn't
like it as much as Star Wars and there
wasn't good very good merchandising for
it yeah there was a lot of toys I got
him I had a model of Vincent the robot
yeah I had a couple little figurines
offense at the robot EFTA I even had the
the little maximilian robot okay yeah
but there wasn't enough wasn't like Star
Wars we could buy a whole bunch of it ya
know and they shoehorned a bunch of
laser gun fights in there you know and
you know that they were trying to
compete with Star Wars actually had they
cut a lot of those laser gun fights and
cuts say like the gunfight scene at the
range between the robots had they cut
that out of there that movie's been a
lot more serious in a lot darker that
does seem like a thing that they just
said now some people are gonna argue
that the whole entire point of the
robots of vinson
an old Bob which were actually voiced by
uncredited Roddy McDowall
and slim pickins yeah and they do an
awesome job I really like those care I
really what I do too it's an all-star
cast
you can tell they stuck him in there for
kids yeah but I didn't really mind them
and I kind of liked how [ __ ] Ronnie
McDowell's robot was like all the little
comments so many people some people
really panned the the movie for the cute
robots yeah I liked it I liked to it
yeah I got on second viewing they were
the highlights
they were the best characters actually
well yeah it's the human characters
weren't really that interesting no they
were kind of boring they were kind of
bad guys they people robot and the two
cute robots yeah they were the bad thing
with heroes maximilian schell was he was
easily the best human character because
he just went for it and just to [ __ ]
scenery like crazy and i respect that i
love it cuz he could a phone nut [ __ ] in
yeah he did not know he's as i'm going
on full on evil man and then he was
saying at the big hair and he was all
crazy and [ __ ] you know the the other
characters like anthony perkins is in
this kind of deadline and it's a very
you know a very deadpan also i didn't
really buy that anthony perkins would
arrive on the ship and then immediately
be like yeah i'm gonna go along with
this clearly crazy you know what you
drive into a black hole you gotta
remember that you know he was well known
for the movie psycho yeah so i think
they were inferring that he was a little
[ __ ] crazy that he was crazy - that
crazy - and that was really come across
that never some other [ __ ] that I picked
up when I was a kid this still kind of
sticks with me a lot of people were mad
that the psychic woman had an ESP or a
psychic linked to that robot yeah that
she could communicate with that robot
psychically people are like what how
didn't you do that well what I had what
I wasn't what I had thought at the time
as a kid is that they were inferring
that that robot had a soul and that's
starting to come into some of the new
sci-fi now that you know that AI is so
good is it alive but is this a real
creature and when you know him and Bob
the other one of his kind we're saying
to each other were the best and they
knew about death yeah and he in here and
in Vince it's giving words of wisdom and
you know quote and you know old would he
call them parables given old parables so
I thought that
what they were trying to say is that Bob
and Vincent had souls well you know one
of the human characters near the very
beginning you remember when Vincent gets
sent out to fix the part of the ship but
he has to go outside of there and you
know the the other guy on the crew is
like oh I got to go out there and get
him he's in trouble he said about the
world what about if he was one of us Gus
and he says he is one of us right so
then you have the bad guy his name is
maximilian schell his in real life yes
his evil robots named maximilian yeah in
the end they join yeah that robot was
evil it was like this satanic robot yeah
that murdered people and you didn't even
need to command him to do it and he
didn't speak yeah so were they trying to
say that yeah that evil robot is really
evil that it is a living sentient
creature in it's evil because in the end
you know then they're little in the hell
scene they merge into one yeah that's
kind of like his punishment and I was
thinking that the doctor which is named
after Hans Zarkov was it what was I
forgot the name the name of the bad guys
last day his first name was Hans
maximilian schell character he did all
the talking but his evil robot didn't
say anything and robots could talk yeah
but not his robot a robot and not his
not his army of zombies they couldn't
tell he did all the talking and he was
all just about his own ego I should note
too that sometimes the robot did stuff
without honza's authorization and he
knew what the robot wanted like they had
a telepathic link also cuz if ever I saw
you have a telepathic length would link
with that robot you just the end I think
he goes amazing interesting but that
evil robot max came to him and just in
they look at each other and he goes oh
okay it's ready the ships yeah how did
he know that right did he have a psychic
link with this yet robot so that was
kind of odd because it's like why was he
so amazed by her psychic link with
Vincent if he had one with Maximilian
yeah was Maximilian him either that
that's what I thought it was yeah it
made kind of like I was like he's in his
it come here Frankenstein mechanical
adverse of himself and in his ballroom
where he feeds them all he's wearing a
Dracula medallion around his and in a
very swanky red
suit yes yeah red suit and it's and it's
a gothic it's a dining room of a gothic
it's very it's all chandelier yeah yeah
but it's a but it's anticipation and
it's been quite cool yeah you just it's
just a the movies got a very dark
audience to it it's got a really good
feel you can't overthink it you just
watch it and kind of take it as a old
Star Trek episode like cat's paw or like
a gothic horror movie like Dracula or
Frankenstein yes yeah bread with
Forbidden Planet yeah actually I think
your comparison with that Star Trek
episode cat's paw which actually and I
think I commented this on one of our
Star Trek days video true I have a soft
spot for pretty much any original Star
Trek episode that was like written by
Robert Bloch they also wrote psycho if
you don't know and was kind of horror
movie based so I loved cat's paw I know
like I don't like that one but I really
like yeah and I want to Jack the Ripper
one tale and that was from that
generation yeah so that's why that movie
came out that way the movie was a little
bit of a throwback even in seventeen
didn't like I liked it as a kid I liked
yeah and actually I liked it a lot more
than I thought I would when I saw it
again no I'm better than ever the
interesting thing about this and maybe
people that are listening and are
younger than us might not remember
because Disney nowadays they're much
more known for their you know quality
animated films and stuff like that but I
think that didn't really come about
until maybe the late 80s or 90s with
their boot you know Aladdin The Lion
King Beauty and the Beast and stuff like
that but you have to think that when the
black hole came out Disney was [ __ ] then
they hadn't had a successful animated
film since the Jonah book which came in
1967 and they had shitty movies like
Herbie the lovebug yes and then they
made a lot of live-action like the cat
from outer space and stuff like that
which i also saw when I was a kid so
this was the beginning of Disney
rebooting itself yeah they wanted to go
more darker like in a more adult or a
direction which eventually they did
because eventually they ended up buying
Miramax Films and they kind of branched
out into other you know they had other
companies under which they could put out
movies that they didn't Ness
certainly want to put the Disney name on
it but that's what I find in the whole
Disney film history
I find this period really interesting
because they put out a lot of
not-so-great movies I mean but then they
had ones like the black hole the Black
Cauldron yeah they both then both of
those movies vanished from yes like that
which didn't do very well yeah but I
admire that they were willing to go in a
darker direction right because some of
the stuff in the black hole are Black
Cauldron is scary or batshit right and I
think that's cold if they actually did
that yeah you know worth it because it
seemed like the 70s were such an
experimental time in film and you could
kind of get away with doing some crazy
[ __ ]
Obie's and you could put scary [ __ ] in
kids movies which not just Disney did
everybody was doing it and I feel like
he Jie didn't mean the same thing back
then that means now I mean I feel like a
lot of kids and I saw this on because I
was reading an article about the black
hole that was written by somebody the
same age as me and there were a lot of
comments after it who people who were
also the same age that remembered seeing
it when they were a kid and they
remembered a lot of things about this
movie that scared the [ __ ] out of them
like Maximilian like Anthony Perkins
taking the mask off that one don't know
spoiled yes doing that like a lot of
people were wigged out by that yeah and
it just reminded me of and they tried to
lobotomize the psychic right I mean
there's a lot of kind of dark [ __ ] in
this may I ask it kind of reminded me
about how in the late 70s early 80s
there were a lot of movies that were
ostensibly marketed toward children put
like watership down for example right
fit were actually if you see them now
are like horrified right and it's like
it would never make that for it damage
interment in terms of space movies at
the time that this came out you got to
remember that from you know from our
point of view what we knew was 2001 and
we knew about Star Wars
maybe silent running yeah it was about
it you know oh and Close Encounters of
the Third Kind yeah so this that was a
little bit later was that was that 81 I
want to say no the nose nose earlier I
believe that that was maybe 78 or
something okay maybe you're right
think it might have been because I think
yeah I think Close Encounters was out by
then I remember it yeah you're right I
think it was
you know Star Trek the net motion
picture I think maybe maybe had just
come out a few months before this it
came right around the same time as a
black alien had not come out again I
don't think this alien was mind blowing
and that changed the game that yeah from
then on out sci-fi had to be more
realistic you can be running around in
space on the outside of your ship
bringing that cloud of black hole does
read black hole does yeah and also just
like kind of parked outside of a black
hole in there anything well you know he
had he was the ship was in an
antigravity field being generated by
this generator inside the ship that made
him so much power you could fuel the
entire Earth yeah and he wasn't
interested in sharing in this technology
of the rest of Earth he he he flim-flam
a whole nation to build that spaceship
you know I mean and then stole it yeah
and got rid of the crew and then
developed technology on it and was gonna
go through this black hole without even
telling anybody about it
basically yeah that's pretty much what
his plan was oh yeah hey the big ego
yeah I miss it I don't you want to go
back and get all the fingers no I don't
care about that anymore I don't care
about you people
the dialogues a little wooden and you
know you could tell us written by an
older generation you know I wouldn't
really but it's it still kind of flies
in a way in the way that Dracula could
fly yeah and that you know a
Frankenstein movie can fly you don't I
mean where you just take it on its own
terms it was from another time I mean
it's paste kind of slowly and stuff like
that but visually it's really nice now
you can tell the many of the scenes that
involve a lot of dialogue those you
could also do those on stage like a
stage play you could do it that way also
that's that's what kind of movie we're
talking about and it's kind of weird
when they'll enter they'll kind of
interweave some Star Wars gunfights in
with that too where that doesn't really
match perfectly but you just have to
take the movie for what it is and the
time in which it was made you know
that's just yeah well sure now I read
that they have been kicking around the
idea of remaking this since about 2009
well I do I did notice that it's become
a cult film and it does have some young
fans yes some younger people have found
it and go man this is quite a cool movie
because there's nothing really like this
city or
yeah they don't make movies like this no
nowadays a movie kind of has to make
sense like that like and I'm all for
that too like and I understand that
particularly sci-fi fantasy horror you
definitely do have to have that grounded
in reality thing otherwise people aren't
gonna come on that journey with you I
like that but I also like I think the
the charm of a lot of the movies that
came out in the 70s and why I still
remember them so fondly it's just
because there's like [ __ ] all that yeah
story we just want to do this because it
looks cool I really don't I mean it's
kind of the same thing and I think I
talked about this a little bit on my
Suspiria view review that I did when you
weren't here is that you know the plot
of the movie doesn't really make all
that much sense mmm but they just kind
of did it just because it's like
wouldn't it be cool if that happened and
they're like yeah do it it was kind of
like you know the meteor shower that
hits the cygnus yeah you look at those
you know that those aren't meteors yeah
no but it is pretty and you know what
happens to the sickness is implausible
that anyone could survive that or the
ship itself could survive that yeah but
who gives a [ __ ] this is a movie well I
don't know I just look cool I think I
have a much more like freewheeling
attitude about movies it's like I'm not
saying that I don't hate some movies
because I do but I think I'm really
willing to take a movie on its own terms
yeah like if they just want to do
something for the [ __ ] of it and they
don't even care if it's realistic or
something we'll be like all right I'll
come with you on that yes you know what
I mean I I feel like I'm more than
willing to give someone the benefit of
the doubt in that way unless it's
clearly done because the person is
stupid and doesn't know any better right
I mean if they made a deliberate choice
look I know this isn't realistic but it
looks awesome so let's do it like that
but you know or a deliberate visual
choice yeah then I can roll with that
it's my understanding based on things
that I've heard and Nina don't quote me
on this but some of the irregularities
in this movie happened because there
were two different production teams
working simultaneously and then after
the footage was shot they kind of
spliced the work of those two teams
together into a movie so it was kind of
cobbled together in a way it does have
that feel in it but yeah because the
towel
slightly irregular yeah a foreboding and
dark for a while and kind of spooky and
then all of a sudden the fight breaks
out and it gets kind of fun for a minute
yeah and then it gets funny for about
two or three minutes and then it goes
back to being darker foreboding yeah it
does kind of feel like they wanted to
make a darker more adult-oriented movie
but then they're like yeah but kids and
then they're like they kind of had to
stick some more funny thing they mates
they made they made a problem they made
a mistake Star Wars was out by the time
you know it was they had been out for
two years
yeah they had time all right to think
about what they were doing when you
actually analyze this story and what
makes this story great there's no way to
make a sequel because the cool things
about this story where it was the Cygnus
the shed don't robot yeah and the bad
guy well at the end of the movie they're
all gone and they in the in the black
hole the black holes gone they went
through it yeah so where is it gonna go
after this yeah no I mean what made this
movie cool is now not there which means
you have to make an entirely different
movie you know what I mean so the sequel
wouldn't be anything like the first one
so that's kind of reminds me I should
have done is they should have made it so
the sickness and the bad guys actually
survived and they're on the other side
of the black hole so the story could
continue they resolved a problem too
quickly I think although I feel like if
they did make a sequel hmm okay so you
could argue that technically maximilian
schell was bad guy didn't really die
because he was like in the hellish
dimension yeah you could bring it you
could bring him back but as a man
machine man good thing he'd be like
super scary yeah and then the whole
thing could take place in the alternate
dimension on the flip side of the black
hole because when they went through the
black hole all right you know the
implication they were all kind of like
yeah a new planet bla bla but they
didn't show anything that would suggest
that that was a cool dimension right so
what if they went through the black hole
and it was this horrible flipside kind
of dimension yeah and what if they were
in a dimension where the Maximilian
Schell Maximilian robot you know
creature was like in charger who's like
an overlord or something like that
the sickness wasn't destroyed it seems
stronger on the other kind like the
mirror universe is something we should
make it a straight-up horror yeah you
can find do it that way you know I'd
watch that yeah some people panned the
robots you know like Vincent and Bob ago
they were too cutesy I liked him
I did too I thought I think they were
one of the strongest I'll these are
adorable but like I really did like I
like too Roddy McDowall yeah he's the
one that's really one of the most
memorable character in the movie if you
ask me in terms of all you know the crew
the Pegasus end the good guys you're
gonna remember Vincent the rest of the
characters are kind of forgivable yeah
they're very blah yeah but you know on
the main I was I'm glad that we're II
watched this cuz I was really curious to
see because I didn't remember anything
about it I was really curious to see
what it was like yeah you know seeing it
now as an adult right and actually I
enjoyed it a lot more than I thought
there's a lot different than I would
never member I remembered it's better
than I remembered it was a little bit
deeper than I remembered it in terms of
what you know what they were trying to
tell us about you know a Faustian pact
you know yeah with with the forces of
evil you know it was a little darker
than I remembered it it's pretty good
yeah I liked it was better than I
thought it was gonna be yeah it's like
actually I liked it a little bit better
see so sometimes it's okay to revisit
what I can tell that it was it was
written for a 20 year old yeah 17 or 18
20 year old has written for them
I was 10 at the time so some of it went
over my head yes I just mostly remember
the robots yeah yeah you know what
that's probably why I didn't really
remember cuz I was expecting to be like
super scary and then I was like what the
hell is it I'm just like dudes talking
yeah anyway that'll probably wrap it up
for this review of 1979 it's the black
hole check it out if you haven't already
you know it gets a lot of hate but
actually I quite enjoyed it it's it's a
cult classic it's nice to look at anyway
very atmospheric so remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media share with all your
friends all that other kind of stuff if
you would like to support the show
please go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast network
calm and there is a link in the sidebar
to a PayPal account if you'd rather give
a one-time donation and that'll do it
for this movie review look out for our
next episode coming out on Tuesday and
we will see you next time